attention this is your final chance to
get this exclusive trash taste merch
there's one week left to get it so go to
trashtaste.com to get some of these
amazing items what do we have boys my
fellow denim jacket wearers we finally
made a denim jacket just for you look at
that look at that look at that
embroidered there oh my God that's
beautiful great quality God and you're
rocking one of the t-shirts as well um I
am I'm Rocky one of the other t-shirts
and Conor is rocking the beautiful
sweatshirt yeah let me show you let me
show you that is
you can see right here in the back we've
got hoodies oh clean but again as Connor
mentioned you only have one week left
after that week it is gone forever don't
complain we gave you a warning so make
sure to go over to trash taste.com links
in the description get it now before
it's over it's trashtaste.com LeBron
James kind of the name is LeBron white
names we all have white I don't have a
white name that's like cursive Grant
what do you mean that's like that's
super white excuse me
at least they're not named after a
dictator like me
no way
if you look up famous Josephs
is gone gaunt name origin sounds
yeah it's gonna say did you mean the
first thing that comes up is
real name explained okay as a nickname
okay all right well let's let's why does
the name go what does the name gaunt
mean let's have a look
um
it's like oh it's uh no one knows
oh it's a Thai name and it's it's not
pronounced
67 Thai 30 Filipino no way
oh southeast Asia alternative meaning
God
there's an acronym for Grand for the
life that you'll live a for accepting
your forgiving nature ah for ROMs you
know how to have fun ah and for
nurturing the care you provide to all
tea for treat the you always are a real
treat well I I just thought God just
sounds it sounds so incredibly white I
just thought it was a white name I think
you do not okay would it still classic
white people okay okay have we started
yeah we started this one okay recording
recording okay hello welcome to trash
station you uh got some pre-talk there I
guess uh I'm is gone he's gone a white
name it sounds white like you gotta do
this
man on Earth his name Grant Hugh Grant
that sounds white as [__] but that's
Grant
it's like one letter different you know
and and the the fact that it's
pronounced like Grant you know gaunt is
uh it's a different like pronunciation
would it still sound white if I remove
the T
gone yeah they sound like a final
fantasy camera
so yeah yeah so interesting fact so my
name isn't actually like gaunts oh my
God so it's actually Grand so we figured
it out yeah yeah so the the Thai
pronunciation of my name is gone
so so the the reason the reason there's
a t at the end is because
um when translating like the Thai
alphabet to English alphabets the T in
God is technically a silent T so my
parents included that my parents did a
direct translations instead of uh
phonetic translation for my name when
translating my like when spelling it out
in English so the tea is meant to be
silent but of course how you can't
really explain that
um so your name would have been really
different if you were called gone
that would have changed everything
different podcasts
but now that I say this just it just
something sounds wrong you know there's
the the tea just like the T closes it
you know you need a hard tea at the end
of that yeah
but yes hello welcome to this episode of
trash taste I'm your host for today
and with me are the two whitest named
boys except jury of course isn't white
I'm sorry Joey
he's got a white name though yeah yeah
Joseph
white name that would have been another
different podcast if my name was Joseph
John Connor and Joseph
but yes sir can I start with the rant oh
god with a with a good old-fashioned
Branch a good old-fashioned tangented
brand that has nothing to do with what
we were talking about but this has been
on my mind for like the past week okay
wow you've been really stewing the soil
yeah I have because uh I think I've had
enough
I [__] despise Cards Against
Humanities and I don't know if I've
talked about this before maybe I have
mentioned this but I've I think I've
reached a breaking point where I can't
take this anymore wait no no one plays
that anymore what you'd be surprised
because what triggered this did you play
it recently yes yeah okay okay for for
the record I've always hated Cards
Against Humanities I I think the only
time I've ever had fun with it was like
maybe Humanity I think it's Humanity
okay there's only one there's only one
Humanity
not enough Humanity it's not a different
planet yeah is it caused Against
Humanity yeah it's just Humanities I
don't know I made videos on it okay okay
um I think the only time I've ever had
fun with it was like the very first time
I played it and then every time
afterwards it's I've grown to like hate
it more and more
um I it went from like just a disdain to
like every [__] okay number one for
some reason reason why is it the only
times I ever played I get to play Cards
Against Humanity is like Anime
conventions Cards Against Humanity for
the longest time for me was like the
anime convention game well because I
feel like wanna be like kind of edge
Lords
[Laughter]
it makes sense it's for people who want
to be funny but can't think of their own
punch lines Yeah well yeah but then
there's also like the online of the
blank cards right yeah it was always
just about being edgy yeah and like who
could make the edgiest joke do you want
to win with a blank card just put in any
like horrible slur and you'll most
likely win it's like that's common see
that's that's not what I don't even like
about it because okay it's this is this
is every like this is every interaction
I've had with cars Against Humanity I'm
at a party or something like oh we're
gathering with some cool friends that I
very much Vibe with we are on a Vibe
we're talking [__] we're making jokes
yeah I'm having a good time and then
someone [__] pulls out cars against
Humanities uh I I keep saying Humanities
someone someone pulls out Cards Against
Humanity because apparently we just
weren't having enough fun just vibing
together and making jokes naturally and
they're like I'm impressed I managed to
get everyone to be like yeah let's do it
I but here's the thing right here's the
thing everyone I I seem like I I've
always thought I'm the [__] crazy one
here I I think I I always think it's
like God's joke
I was crazy I didn't want to play the
card games I always thought I was the
crazy one because everyone would be like
okay yeah I'm down for cars Against
Humanity and I'm I thought I was the
only one that was like I am not it was a
Humanity
no I I am not against cars Against
Humanity and the thing is I can't
Against Humanity yeah I'm just Against
Humanity this is
story if someone pulls out another game
one vibing I am literally you're going
to go on like a full-on joker rant and
just start my villain Arc right because
I I it's just like they pull it out and
I've never encountered a situation where
everyone goes where someone just goes no
I'm not in the mood right because I've
said before I'm not in the mood and I'm
the only [__] who says that and
you know and I say that but everyone
else starts playing so I'm like well I
don't want to be I have to play because
I don't want to be left out in the
corner by myself being uh being alone or
whatever so for the next like hour or
two hours I have to sit there and
pretend that I'm having fun as much fun
as everyone else because I have to
pretend that uh all of these jokes that
be are being laid out in front of me are
as funny as everyone else is apparently
finding it because people are laughing
uh and I'm like am I [__] crazy is
this just not funny I think the problem
with Cards Against Humanity is that like
the especially a lot of the jokes
written on it and like the punch lines
and stuff like that that haven't aged
tremendously well yeah they're very much
like you know 2010s humor which is crazy
to say it was a lot more fun when you
um online because you could just make
your own country index yeah yeah and you
can make it updated because the base
deck is so bad the base deck is so
boring I mean also like you know this is
popular in like 2012 yeah years ago yeah
yeah this this game is definitely
here's here's the thing I I you can make
the argument that he hasn't aged well as
well right but I have the same emotions
and feelings towards jackbox and it's a
specifically quip lash which I think you
say some of the uh the trivia ones are
really the trivia ones are good I like
the trivia ones but as soon as quiplash
comes on
is the word association game oh I hate
that one the the feeling like you you
it's basically Cards Against Humanity
yeah yeah yeah but you fill in the
blankets and they bring it back every
single [__] Jack yeah yeah and you
think it would be funny Until you
realize until someone realizes right
here's his his here's what I hate about
it because once you play it once you
figure out what the rules of the game
are right and if there's one thing that
is not funny to me it's when humor just
feels constructed and unnatural right
because that's that's exactly what Cards
Against Humanity and now quiplash has
always felt to me because even though
you can put anything in quiplash when
that one mate realizes all you need to
do is to put that in joke that the group
know about everyone starts putting that
in and then that's like you all it takes
is just one one of those answers where
everyone's like you refer to that one
time we all did this stupid thing or
that person did that stupid thing once
uh once not also gets put down that
ruins the entire game of whiplash
because every answer is if it doesn't
come up then it's usually like the
[__] stupid as ppaper yeah I like the
presentation ones too they have to do in
uh Jack box you have to present
something yeah I always like those as
well the patently stupid one yeah like a
painting yeah oh yeah that one's good
yeah I like some of the games but yeah
quick flash is kind of is the one I
don't really ever want to play yeah and
because like it's it's just to me that's
Cards Against Humanity 2.0 and I feel
there are so many clones of that game
too like yeah everywhere I remember like
I was at a friend's place and they
brought out this card game uh it's
called that's what she said
and it literally is exactly exactly the
same as Cards Against Humanity except
all the punch lines are yo mom jokes and
I'm like I it I I was blown away I was
like you've somehow managed to make a
card Against Humanity that's even less
funny Than Cars Against Humanity it was
hell it was the worst 30 minutes of my
life yeah it's just unfortunate because
I don't want to say that unfortunately a
lot of people just aren't funny
bucks if there's one way to make someone
unfunny it's by Playing Cards Against
Humanity because there is a lot of
points where you know you know I'm
hanging out with a funny person you know
or you know we're cracking jokes and
then as soon as cars Against Humanity
comes up that just like completely Nerfs
the interaction right
um and I don't know it's I I always feel
like
every time he gets put out I'm that guy
who just hates fun I'm like am I am I
the crazy one here because I I I've
wanted to rant about this for so long
because I've always felt like am I just
the one old Grandad who just hates
watching people have fun oh no because
you can have fun in other ways there's a
difference between hating someone having
fun playing a card game like hey I'm
good on this one you guys play without
me yeah I don't get pissed I'm not like
[__] [__] I said no why are you
having fun without me I'm like how are
you how I'm like how [__] dare you
have fun at this card game this this is
what you're having we could have had any
other card game except this one pathetic
it is like the worst card game I feel
like there's like Solitaire is better
because you know the good thing is at
least you can banter in Solitaire you
can't really banter and Like Cards
Against Humanity is on paper a game you
should be able to Banter about but it's
all just it's all just the equivalent of
laughing at pee pee poo poo jokes in my
mind uh and uh just like a bit more
sophisticated jokes yeah this is when
you're making energy jerk as well I was
like wow that's too far what do you mean
like half these cards are like [__]
there's the other ones where it's like
you know there could be a white card
down you're sifting through all of yours
and then you find one you just start
bursting and laughing that creates an
expectation and then when your car gets
red and no one laughs it makes so many
awkward moments because you can't be the
only one to laugh because then you'll
know that yeah yeah or or that or that
moment where there's like there's that
you know I've played games where there's
moments where I'm just like there's I
think I've put down a banger right I
think I've put down the [__] Banger
uh and I think the worst thing they
picked the worst [__] unfunniest
option makes absolutely zero sense and
I'm like
I'm I I I hate this I hate this game on
so many different levels and just uh
yeah I was in a I was in a situation
recently when someone like just took it
out again and I'm like maybe maybe it's
changed it's been it's been years it's
been years since I played cards it's
been years and I played one game I
played like two two hands and I'm like
I'm done I this is this is my Breaking
Point never again but uh yeah I don't
know if it's specifically cars Against
Humanity or if I just have an aversion
to board games uh I don't have like so
much in adversion to board games
I just realized that a lot of the times
if there's an option to let's say you
hang out with a group of friends uh if
there's an option just to like Vibe with
each other or an option to do something
active like play a game I would always
at a party like a physical party like
choose just like vibing
um and I don't know if that's just a me
thing or my brain thing because I do
genuinely have fun playing board games
it's the idea of
like ruining the let's say ruining the
not the momentum but like they're kind
of like the the board game's kind of in
the way right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the board game's in the way
um we have fun but it's like a different
kind of fun you know and I don't know I
it's maybe it's just a me thing because
I if there's a specific board game night
I'm always down because like there's a
let's say there's a expectation you're
gonna go to this it's like going to a d
d session right there's an expectation
that you're gonna go to this and you can
sit down and you can play a board game
and I'm like okay I can mentally prepare
for that but if we're just at a social
Gathering or like a party and someone
brings out a kind of game I'm like this
is just socializing on training wheels I
would rather just socialize with my
mates so you can say that because you're
a social Master guy
well more of a master than like than the
[__] pulls out Cards Against
Humanity yeah I think it's like an
icebreaker for some people it's right
you like kind of get rid of that tension
in the air uh
yeah I I agree I'm I'm I agree with you
I don't know but oh wow oh wow something
all three of us can finally agree it's
kind of hard to just say that all right
I saw you fighting internally yeah I I I
I agree I agree
surprise yourself with that that wasn't
I mean that was not a hot day you were
like something that came out 10 years
ago not funny now we wanted to come out
it came out like longer than 10 years
ago because that's what I only ever
played the online version the online
version I think came out in like 2010
2009 something like that maybe Cosmic
Humanity uh release date
why is this the top question well what's
the top question it's cards against you
empty okay for 13 year olds
uh and apparently it's appropriate for
All Humans age eight and up eight and up
eight and up excuse me I distinctly
remember I feel like it's burning my
mind it's like what the [__] black
tar heroin card I don't know why what
it's just this really unfunny card that
I used to always get when I played it it
was like black tar heroine was one of
the prompts and I was like this is just
not funny oh one that I always remember
is SpongeBob's nut sack and I'm like
when was this ever funny I mean there's
just some random ones that were
obviously there for filler like I
remember getting a card that was just
bees like what what can I do with this
there's also bees like with a question
mark as well that always comes off and
I'm like when would I use this yeah what
how can I how can I ever use this card
but oh no one card I always remember
which was actually funny was getting
gang banged by the Blue Man Group
okay
you're that [__]
18.
it's always
no I agree though it's uh I feel like
we've you know maybe it's like kind of
our age or you know the fact that we've
had we've been in so many social
situations that we just kind of want to
chill but like yeah I don't have a
problem with people like kind of
bringing up like board games or card
games and stuff like that during a
hangout but I'm like yeah I just feel
like it's just in the way like it's
unnecessary no I don't mind it just
depends on the game's [__] or Not Right
But even if the game is fun I'm just
like well but like I was having fun just
talking to you guys you know just having
fun like drinking chatting and chilling
you know I thought that's the kind of
vibe we're going for like you know if if
someone pulls out Monopoly I'm not gonna
be like [__] no actually I am going to
be like I will not because I was super
competitive
I'm like I'm buying out all the streets
but like you know if yeah if there's a
night where it's just like you're just
hanging out chilling drinking and that's
how it starts and that's how it ends
then I think I prefer that over any
other type of like event yeah you know I
feel like to me if you're going to pull
something like out like that like the
simpler the better for me like I don't
know there's like Uno or something right
who knows I like you know I do not like
you enough
we did it on after dark okay who knows
like fun for like the first five minutes
and then you have that game that runs on
for like way too [__] long and you're
just like can can this just end skill
issue it's not it's not a skill it's
like you're an amateur I don't know how
to say it yeah I mean it's it's yeah
like I said you have that game that runs
on I mean it happened the [__] after
dark stream where we had that game that
ran for like 40 minutes yeah but that
was funny
my mind is melting right now I feel like
only too many numbers and colors what do
I do I feel like I needed to use more
neurons in my brains
I I have yes
the sequel to truth it's so good is that
a joke
this is a [__] post I'm hearing right
now
what are the rules of the game I don't
know I haven't played it I don't know I
was really drunk when I played it it's
basically just like you know I think
except like the numbers are different
yeah you get rid of like two cards on a
car or something
I I just remember it looked funny I was
like oh it's blue
oh you know who knows red and black yeah
yeah complete rules for dos card game is
it could they just say if there's a
difference why
if Uno means one then dos means two
thank you that's great I've did they
really need to make that felt like an
unnecessary sequel I like Bruno was
crushing it yeah we really need another
but I don't know attack I liked who
knows yeah yeah that was more that was a
bit more gameplay too okay so here we go
like Uno you have to discard your cards
by matching the cards in the center but
in DOS you can only match them by number
right so the numbers need to be matched
first then only the color is noted so
basically it's like a harder version of
it that's never going to take off which
is like why do you need a separate game
for that when you can just add
importance
the skill ceiling isn't high enough on
it yeah so that's that's my kind of made
it for real you know ranked Gamers
that's right
you wouldn't understand it's it's for
people with intelligence you need a
number of IQ to play Dorsey yeah someone
I'm I'm hoping they didn't put too much
effort into making the rules for that
because that was all obviously never
going to that was never going to take I
could see why no one's played this
[__] game yeah I don't know anyone
who's played dos again I played it once
I don't remember playing it though I
think I just played it as Uno who bought
the deck
uh I was in uh no you know where it was
it was at the Final Fantasy Cafe because
next to it they have a board game Cafe
yeah and they had dos there yeah and I
was like what the hell is this and that
was the first time I saw Final Fantasy
no next to the Final Fantasy Cafe
there's a board game Captain yeah well
the Final Fantasy Cafe you wanna play
boss
Final Fantasy 14 actually like triple
Triad right but different I get that
reference now
I know he finally gets it after you
finally completed yeah I played the
Final Fantasy game I wasn't did you good
yeah I liked it yeah I liked it
um I everyone told me I played the worst
one how old did you play the worst yeah
that's the worst one who says it's the
worst a lot of people tell me it's one
of the worst ones probably seven fans
said that [__] they said that well I I
the reason when they tell me why I was
bad I was like yeah I agree with you so
Final Fantasy 8
um is you know has a traditional
turn-based combat similar to the other
final fantasies yeah I assume except
they added the system called Drawing uh
so to get spells you have to like absorb
them from enemies that is the worst part
um and then you're like you're like
let's say your magic power is assigned
to how many of those abilities you have
right so if you only drained like two of
those spells you only get like two so
more often not you just end up sitting
there in fights yeah and just heal
healing your team and just absorbing
yeah like ages right it's [__] but the
game is fun though and I did enjoy the
the story yeah did you skip the
cutscenes you can't
I didn't I liked it I thought it was fun
stories fantastic yeah I got I was like
I feel like I've played so many jlpgs in
like that's caps
I should rephrase that yeah I feel like
I've experienced many jlpgs just became
five yeah
I've had that thing where it's like okay
save the Dog final mission kill God go
back in time save 15 people kill another
dog and then come back and then reset
the universe like what the [__] that's
the greatest part of gopg yeah and I
feel like that's every single jlpg I've
played like that's end up you always go
back in time and kill someone yeah but
that's like saying like every FPS is
just like mission one shoot the man yeah
shoot everyone the difference between
just like go to your village and get
some flour for the bread and then go
back in time and then stab him in the
heart yeah that's why it's epic because
it starts it starts off low and then the
expectation builds yeah but it kind of
got like I mean I'm sure back in the day
because this was a 1999 game I think
this one yeah this would have been a
mind-blowing experience but I was like
God damn do we really need to go to
space
yeah the answer is every every Japanese
like fiction yeah every Japanese piece
of fiction media is like and now we will
end with space
the trigger it's just like how do we
finish this Epic fantasy story
anybody's face
but I enjoyed it uh I thought that you
know um it was decent how long did it
take you to complete
of gameplay 30 hours oh that's pretty
sure that's quite quick that's actually
that's pretty what [__] world are you
living in oh that's for a jrpg fantasy
yeah quite quick I thought you would be
playing for at least 50 hours yeah did
you have any like accelerators on
anything like that or yeah the game is
times three built in okay that makes
sense times three by all is it always
times three but during the you know when
you're drawing these abilities yeah yeah
because when I played eight the first
time I took at least 50 hours holy [__]
the walking speed around the Overworld
on times three was just was like okay
this is nice and then I turned it off I
was like this is unbearable
it's not like like [__] honkai fans
feel when they finally discovered
there's a normal speed
why is it in slo-mo
um it's like in Pokemon when you learn
how to run finally it's just like oh my
God finally I don't know if this is like
strictly like this game's problem but
another a thing that I I and I think I
think a lot of video games do this in
general
they assume you have played video games
right yeah so like when you go on a
first person shooter they just assume
you have played other first person
shooters yeah right like there's just
things that they don't tell you and they
just assume you're like oh you know what
you're doing yeah I don't want to point
the gun and shoot yeah you know you know
that the if this Mass buttons to click
we don't need to tell you the other
Mouse buttons to aim you know that same
with the triggers like you just like
there's a bunch of things they just
think you know and I realized that Final
Fantasy just assumes you know how to do
RPG stuff and I got in this menu and I
was like what the [__] is this they
start telling you like press this do
this and I'm like this is too much stop
stop so the first five hours of the game
I was like I don't know what I'm doing I
just I just did not understand the menus
because it's too much yeah it's like
you've got to assign this character this
and then uh but he is into jrpgs yeah
designing summons they're like yeah and
then like they're like oh sign the
summons then what a summons you assign
uh allow them to pick from these
abilities and these abilities let them
do this but are you gonna pick three
abilities and then they have uh
abilities that are tied to their
offensive defense and uh I guess other
offensive but it's not their other but
they have a completely other stat for
like offensive stuff as well and you're
like what the [__] is this what happened
to my what the hell and people were like
uh that seems pretty standard to me yeah
yeah and then I just luckily there was
an auto optimize button so I would just
click that and I was like it's good
enough we're like no what are you doing
and I was like all right listen I didn't
I don't get drunk you still completed
the game which is the importance I'm
exactly yeah everyone acts like jrpgs
are impossible if you don't do like the
perfect one frame optimization and it's
like dude these games are beaten by like
five-year-olds yeah it's not I want an
auto button for every grpg honestly yeah
yeah I think if you have like I I think
I Final Fantasy Android and and towards
the end of it you know the menuing kind
of got a little more fun as I got really
into it yeah but that was like I'm
talking like 15 hours in yeah that's and
I'm halfway through the goddamn game
before I started getting like oh this is
kind of fun to Theory crafting kind of
thing but I think it's just too much
it's like I think I spent 40 of my game
time in a menu yeah because I think it's
just too much for me like I've had that
kind of those kinds of moments where I'm
like are you you know there's there's
something magical about figuring out
your mechanics and I tried this
combination yeah and the fact I hit him
with this yeah yeah because I'm that
type of guy who you know in the first
like sometimes you know jrpgs their
tutorials are like last eight hours long
yeah yeah like you're still gonna
introduced something eight hours into
the gameplay
um and I'm that [__] who reads
something other than just like a gun
yeah it's gone it's gone like I'm like
uh so this does this and I like see the
words and I process it
but then it doesn't like stick with me
yeah I do that too I'm that kind of guy
who needs to see like cause and effects
yeah I need to try it out I need to like
put the stability on yeah hit someone
with it be like no yeah the amount of
times like I've been like streaming like
you know recently of course like honkai
I've got a character and I'm like let me
let me read what the skill does and chat
tells me what the skill does and I I I'm
like oh I get it I don't get it
I'll read it I'll read it and I'll be
like can someone tell me in simpler
English they're like it's good or it's
bad I'm like thanks guys equip it or
don't it quit yeah and then I go into
battle and then sometimes I die and I'm
like oh okay I get it now you know and
one thing I've I've I've always hated
about some jrpgs and and I guess this is
the problem is that sometimes like like
you know I was complaining to give me
too much information yeah I'm like what
the [__] is this and then the bane of my
existence when you're reading an ability
and you're like will cause a slight
increase to to Critical Strike chance
and you're like can you give me a number
like like because slight could be from
anywhere between 0.1 to like 10. yeah
and and one one percent attempt is a
massive difference here we're like this
is the difference between this just
being a random once in a [__] Blue
Moon One play run one playthrough chance
it'll happen or this will happen fairly
often in battle and I'm like yeah it's
pissing me off that it doesn't it'll
literally it'll literally tell me the
[__] length of every character when I I
choose them and every hair follicle
amount they have left but it won't tell
me the goddamn [__] abilities like
actual information that I need I think
it's because no one's expecting people
to use that item as like a crutch yeah
for their gameplay you know they're just
like oh it's just like an added bonus
right right if it happens cool if it
doesn't hey it's all right I've got
these other [__] you know yeah like uh
what game was I playing or it was like
oh um if I used
there's a game like if I use like oh it
was like ring fit yeah ring fit right I
was playing ring fit and it was like if
you use a red ability after I unlock
this thing on the skill tree it's like
there's a there's a chance it'll cause
another free attack and I was like oh
chance what does that mean what would
you consider a chance to be
there's a turn-based combat and they
said yeah if you use a fire ability and
you and you have this point unlocked you
have a chance to get another one maybe
10 yeah what would you I didn't know
what number to magically pull out my ass
yeah to like decide what this would be I
thought 10 or 20 because that's what a
chance sounds like to yeah yeah sounds
like listen now don't get your hopes up
but it'll happen
you know and so I was like okay cool I
win the whole [__] game and I didn't
get one and I was like see that see that
that's [__] because I went through the
skill tree to get that chance because I
read it and I thought oh that sounds
strong yeah like an extra turn that's
great yeah and then it must have been
like one percent
really [__] unlucky yeah yeah either
way I wish that like they gave me a
number and it's like the one time the
one time I want a number they don't give
me the [__] number but wouldn't it
have pissed you off more if you saw that
number and it was like instead of chance
if it said like you have a one percent
no I'd love that because I can be like
that's absolute garbage I can
immediately not even entertain right I
can just go straight past it yeah
um and there was also I the one thing I
always enjoyed
um because I did play some jrpgs or RPGs
when I was a kid and I always enjoyed
those like weird little like fun little
Easter eggs you could run into or you're
like go right here and then do this
thing and you'll find this crazy boss
and you're like oh that's cool yeah um
yeah and they had I've had plenty of
those it's fun yeah it's interesting
when you mention like the kind of like
the kind of assumptions when it comes to
like approaching a video game or just a
video game genre I remember seeing like
a pretty interesting video I like about
this yeah the ones where I can't
remember the name of the video but it
was the one where the guy got his wife
your girlfriend wife I'm not sure which
one to who has zero basically zero
experience with video games and got it
to play a bunch of video games and see
how intuitive like the video game was
for this person who has zero experience
no they're not very yeah yeah exactly
and you realize how ingrained the the
language of video games are in your mind
right and make it makes me think about
just how ingrained every kind of piece
of UI or computer is like you know when
you're teaching your grandma to be like
how does this not make sense if you get
an error message it means this and you
have to click this this uh I'm just like
the simplest thing that you've kind of
just
internalized
um that you take for granted that might
if you have zero experience with it uh
you would know because we've had a very
lucky kind of like journey to be able to
see video games experience video games
at their simplest and be able to like I
guess grow up with it and and slowly
learn the language a little bit by
little bit yeah um because I remember
the first time I think I experienced
this was like playing a Souls like a
soulsborne game and just not knowing oh
yeah what the rules are at all I'm like
where are the tutorials where is the
things that tells me what the mechanics
are where to do what to do and I thought
you know first time I played I was like
this is [__] but it's not telling me
anything how can I how how am I supposed
to play the game but you know when
you've realized that sense of discovery
of discovering Mechanics for yourself
and discovering the little things that
maybe the devs have put in there that
weren't in a tutorial stage that to me
is way [__] better than giving me
eight hours of menus and tutorial
screens to be like you can do this for
this and you can do that for that and
I'm not going to internalize that anyway
and I'm like I'm sure I'm sure I'll
figure it out somewhere along the line
yeah yeah right yeah it just sucks I
felt like I figured it out halfway
through the game I was like okay I think
I get it but that's to me that's that's
when I've normally figured out that's
normally when I've had that magic moment
I that's I think that's why it always
takes me like so long to get into a new
video game is because I've I I really
start figuring things out around like
eight to fifteen hours through my
gameplay yeah
yeah yeah so because I'm a story gamer
so
I'm a story gamer so I never go in for
the mechanics so I'm like what what are
these [__] [__] things in the way
of my story I don't give a [__] about
that just give me like the auto thing
and then halfway through Maybe by
normally it's like by complete chance
something cool happens that I don't plan
for I I've done do unintentionally I'm
like yo what what the [__] was that that
was actually really cool actually and
then that's when I that's when a game
goes from a good game to a game like I
become obsessed with yeah um if it can
just sell me on the mechanics like
sure accidentally as well I'm gonna play
more final fantasies I think yeah you're
gonna play more final fantasies I think
about the original Seven because
everyone says that's good and I I [__]
on the graphics a lot so I was kind of
like maybe I should the [__] egg
beater yeah no they look like Roblox
characters or Worse
um oh that I don't know everyone says
tan everyone's just like yeah Pete keeps
saying six yeah
because every every single [__] uh
old person magazine is like six is the
best for real Gamers because it's it is
it's the Pinnacle of Final Fantasy
design it is but it's on the SNES and
I'm like dude it's from my twitch chat
they're like 12. oh okay yeah okay
it was uh yeah I liked it the story was
okay though I think it was okay yeah
because it felt like I don't know if
other jrpgs do this it was like in the
start it's like hey we got the gang the
gang's great and like halfway through
the game like all right um only the main
characters really matter now so only the
main two everyone else is kind of like
on the side yeah 10 10 I feel definitely
has a better story
um like the system the the combat system
and like the the the power scaling
system as well like this favorite system
is like actually intuitive and yeah yeah
it looks makes it look like [__] oh man
I kind of uh yeah I'm thinking about
that I was like damn I've been playing
fortnite lately that's been kind of fun
fortnite's kind of beautiful fortnite's
kind of good you know what I'm telling
you fortnite's good again when you said
your audience were 12 I thought you were
joking as well I got roped into playing
a few games of fortnite I was like
okay I was like all right fine I'll play
one game and I was like I'm not playing
football that's for little babies
instead of playing outside oh [__] it's
kind of fun though I am a little baby
oh [__] oh [__] it is kind of fun uh so
I'm on the the two sides of the game of
spectrum at the moment I'm a dabbling my
feet in all of it yeah yeah um this is
fun I've been really enjoying gaming
lately actually I kind of fell out of it
for a little while I've been getting
back into it and I've been really into
it
well I was only really playing TFT I hit
Master by the way nobody asked
um the season ended but I hit Master
which is crazy because I never hit
Master before that's like the top not
the top top because it's still two
people but it's pretty crazy for League
it's pretty hard to do yeah um so I was
happy I believe you Joey's sick was just
the most neutral I'm happy for you but I
have no idea what you're talking about
it's like a big virginity
I'm not gonna read that but I'm happy
I was just like casually playing that
and I was like cool that's cool that I
managed to do something while casually
doing it like yeah like committing not
like I played way more on the tour so I
was like oh man I should only get
diamond back then I was ready yeah yeah
I mean I I've uh I guess I've fallen in
love with gaming as well or something
you know I don't know
for the first time yeah I've been
playing uh Jedi Survivor recently oh
[__] I didn't expect you to play that
yeah I mean I mean here's the thing like
I said I really want to get like I said
this on the previous podcast where I
really [__] in love soulsborne games I
just don't like the setting and uh you
know I don't like the Dark Fantasy
setting uh so despite how good they are
it takes me a lot to get invested into
it because you know it it takes a really
good game to get me invested into it uh
Jedi survivors is just the setting that
I [__] love which is not exactly Star
Wars but futuristic sci-fi with the same
kind like enough of the same kind of
gameplay that you'd expect not as good
as Elden ring which is why I think I'm
warming up to like finally starting
Eldon ring maybe on stream because I've
really really enjoyed Jedi Survivor
um I've been enjoying that I've been
enjoying the exploration but one thing
like the the one I wouldn't say downside
okay
as a gamer do you care about Cosmetics
no we're we're in what way okay so Jedi
Survivor is kind of diff uh similar to
like something like you know Elden ring
or something where you explore the world
there are bosses and sometimes there are
a lot of chests and uh what I've
realized is that most of the chests they
they dropped like lightsaber parts or
blaster parts or clothing and jrpg mind
originally I thought oh great start
upgrades let me just equip everything
nope it's all completely cosmetic and
I'm like who cares about this yeah I'm
sure there are people who do
I'm the reason why micro transactions
exist because I I only care about
Cosmetics when it's interacting with
other players because then it's like
it's important to like it's like like in
an MMO or something would I dress nicely
if I never left my house no is the
answer right yeah because no one's
seeing it right it's like that in video
games too I'm like I want to make sure
everyone sees my little funny but you're
out of the house
I say that as if I didn't
listen I I found more skin than I stuck
to it yeah
um so it's like that yeah I mean I if
you if I don't give a [__] about single
player I I want whatever stats the
highest yeah yeah give me start up Grace
yeah which is why like I never
understood like you know I'm that kind
of guy who has never understood the
types of people who when they start a
new game and they see the character
Creations they get [__] excited like
oh my God I get to create my character
and they spend like three hours making
their characters and I'm like those are
people who have drawn their OCS before
the same type of thing yeah
time that
creating is
is all armor or some [__] that you're
never going to see in your life you know
I see a sliver of their customers
pick the dick length it didn't matter I
didn't even get to see it if I I wish
there was like a scene at least utilized
it yeah they were like oh you gotta I
want to see a cutscene where my OC and
his micro [__] it's just like sticking
out yeah like cyberpunk made the least
sense to me because that's the first
person [__] game you don't ever see
your character because like 90 of the
time because it's like I do like it in
cutscenes though and your characters
like looks goofy as [__] oh that's why I
like it in GTA yeah because I can't see
this [__] hilarious when you just
like rocking there's some really serious
scene just your goofy ass is just
standing there that'll do that yeah you
got like a naked man in like a cutscene
I love that I love that so much that
cracks me up yeah but then when it cuts
in the characters wearing like the pre
you know the cut scenes already been
dying like [__] this yeah
yeah just like for me just give me the
default character the just give me like
the default everything I didn't really
care I hate it when you get that kind of
stuff in chess because then you just
turn your brain off to like chests or
whatever you're like it's all going to
be [__] yeah yeah yeah exactly which is
which is why I've enjoyed it but I've
kind of like now that I'm like 20 hours
in or something I'm like I don't want to
explore anymore because 90 of the [__] I
find is just cosmetic stuff that doesn't
matter and I know there is like some
upgrades in the world but I'm like this
just like around this corner could just
be another chest I don't know like is it
actually worth it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that sucks I've also been playing
balloons tower defense again
actually I was I was I was uh on my
computer
it balloons tower defense and I was like
it's kind of streaming and he's I said
and he there was no C doc stream and I'm
like this motherfucker's just playing
Blues tower defense for fun I had like
40 minutes and I was like I watched this
YouTube video because I've been in that
phase again where I gotta listen to
YouTube videos to sleep and I found this
it was like a three hour video video
about balloons tower defense I had like
eight million views and I was like oh I
know this is gonna be a banger and uh
that's when I yeah that's how I know
when essays they were good when you just
see like a stupid view count with a
weirdly specific topic yeah yeah yeah
this is good [__] yeah and I watched it
and I was like ah I kind of want to get
back into Bloons and I started playing
it I was like oh it's kind of good this
kid is good they have it is correct it's
a solid game yeah for sure because they
just keep up dating it that sort of
stuff it's bad because I'm playing it
and and I I feels like a five minute
game and I and I look at the timer I'm
like dude I've been playing this for 40
minutes and I it's I've badly done
anything I'm just watching the balloons
pop it's like it does feel like I'm
developing ADHD while I'm doing it like
I feel like I'm I'm like this feels like
a weird hack on my brain to like
magically lose time
um so I've been doing I've been trying
to get it on second monitor but it keeps
loading on my main monitor see I can't I
can't laugh at that because I've also
recently just casually gotten back into
playing Minesweeper
well because like ages ago when I was
still streaming I I did that you know
offhand stream where I was like I'm
gonna learn how to play mine sweeper and
I put it up and I planned it up playing
it for like five hours I beat expert
once during that entire Stream So I was
but then I was like I could get a better
time and so last couple of days I've
just been whenever I have time I just
put some music on like put something on
the record player and I just [__]
[__] I don't want to ever hear it from
you if you're busy now [__] I don't want
to ever hear the excuse that you're busy
do you know I just realized uh so it's
been it's been two weeks since the last
trash days recording since I had like a
week holiday is this the type of [__] we
get up to when we have no trash Chase
recordings in a week
I have made sure that I've been busy but
occasionally you have like an hour you
know I have to I have to I have to and
then normally I would play TFT but I
stopped because I reached mastered I'm
like I was waiting for a business call
it was two hours down I was like what am
I gonna do for two hours
for two hours
[Music]
that's a long time I was doing like 30
minutes of balloons
it's a good game no it's not it is on
yeah I don't know I I feel like there I
I feel like those kinds of game is just
like the the equivalent of watching Tick
Tock with Subway Surfer at the bottom
you know it's just a way just to keep
your mind engaged yeah uh it is
I was like my brain could just like rot
on the couch doing nothing or it could
stay active and Young by playing
Minesweeper for two yeah because I never
really got like I never really got how
the kind of Rise of idol games came out
like was like Cookie Clicker or whatever
that game was like I never I never like
to me I never understood how that became
a genre well it's I mean I think that
like
it's like people are just want to do
something else then quickly you just
kind of you have to actively do it and
stop then you can just kind of watch it
yeah and it's you know it's like how you
maybe you would you know you'd watch
your TV and talk to your friend back in
the day I feel like it's just evolutions
of that right
is it is it it's just the brain getting
all scattered it is I I feel like it's
just a like something hacking in our
brain because I thought it was like dumb
until uh like honkai Star rail released
this uh uh event recently where it's
like a museum management thing it's not
Museum management all you do is you
click you click buttons and then you see
numbers go up and then you have to get
it so every every number is S rank and
then I've realized that I wasted like
two and a half hours so that's just the
yuck as a side quest
that's literally this like the stock
broker game in Yonkers yeah yeah
and I'm like whatever I'm like why am I
doing this right now and why can I not
stop why why can I not stop something is
going wrong with my brain right now
I just but that was the best part of
some of the youngsters those like
[__] like business management side
quests where you just click some [__]
and you watch it grow got it yeah all
I'm doing is watching some numbers get
bigger and the more numbers get bigger
the more resources you have to make the
bigger numbers get even bigger and then
and then it's like the gameplay Loop of
big numbers equal bigger number and more
big resources equal bigger number and
then it's just and and then it doesn't
end I'm like what why why am I doing
this I don't know why I'm doing this but
I can't stop because I need to see
bigger numbers internally satisfying
that's a YouTube mentality
I mean yeah we do that with our sub
count as always
keep going that is just YouTube in a
nutshell bro this is what trash taste
gets up to when uh when we don't have a
tragedies recording apparently Gamers
this podcast is brought to you by cash
app with tools for saving and spending
it's the best place for you to level up
your money and glow up your life all it
takes to pay someone is their phone
number email or cash tag you can even
scan their QR code straight from the app
not only that you can keep track of your
coin with your balance updated
immediately so you always know when a
payment went through so you can pay me
back now easily right Joe yeah totally
whatever you have my phone number email
and my cash though yeah totally not only
that you can save on everyday spendings
get exclusive discounts with the cash
app pay and cash card and not only that
but you can Bank the way that you want a
simpler faster way to bank without so
many fees I've been playing Final
Fantasy 16 recently and I've learned the
joys of leveling up in video games but I
wish I could learn the joys of leveling
up in the real world as well with my
spending habits that's what cash app is
here to do for me so if you're like Joe
and you want to level up your life
you've got to level up your money so
download cash app in the app store
Google Play with the link description
down below and with no hidden fees and a
free to order debit card it feels like a
cheat code for your finances so do it
download the app down below back to the
episode but uh you're gonna be happy
Connor why finally watched John Wick 4.
oh you did yeah America yeah in America
oh [__] unfortunately I didn't watch
John Wick 3. what the [__] what the [__]
is wrong with you you you Rose it up and
then I went back down I will say I don't
really think it matters because that
implies that the plot in John Wick
actually matters which yeah okay
it all doesn't [__] matter oh my yes
it does the plot is fine you don't even
know the why why what the [__] it's okay
because uh didas was like we're watching
John Wick 4 now and uh you know I was
like I haven't just seen John with three
and he's like I don't care I'll just
explain everything to you
um yeah I don't know you probably don't
even know oh my God like there's so many
like the starting scenes are all like
the the the
[__] backstory to what happened in
the previous movie The reason why oh my
God I mean okay listen you can still
enjoy the movie but like you're missing
out on some pretty good story it's not
the best but it's great man you are the
whole friendship between when the [__]
my God man you just ruined
no because every time something relevant
to like the previous films happened he
would be like he would literally like
pause and be like okay so this happened
this happens you didn't watch it in the
cinemas uh no we uh [__] have we watched
it on like uh home Cinema stream yeah uh
yeah he would just pause it and just
explained everything that happened and
everything he was explaining I was like
uh that's really useful information that
I don't give a [__] about I just want to
see uh people shoot the [__] out of each
other
um
I think John Wick 4 had the best action
I you know I've seen in a [__] long
time the action scenes were absolutely
[__] stunning but I'm gonna kill you
I did not think it needed to be three
hours long I I felt I felt fatigued
after the person because you weren't
invested in the story
okay okay here's my biggest here's my
biggest gripe with it okay here's my
here's my here's my biggest gripe okay
if we wanted it to be longer okay if
we're gonna okay if we're gonna like
talk about the story right
there are some things where I just like
could not wrap my head around uh don
Yen's character all right donnian's
character uh so I didn't know coming
into this that he's a blind he's a blind
guy right you mean you [__] see he's
blind he's not in any of the movies no
no I mean I I didn't know coming into
this movie that he was going to be a
blind character
um well so I I so I thought that he was
going to be some like [__] Daredevil
kind of character who could like sense
everything based on like his sense of
like sound or something and then like
the first scene it becomes very obvious
that oh no he's actually blind and it
doesn't help him at all right why would
it help him I think I'm being blind
gives you superpowers she was Marvel
you've seen so much anime
he's like no he's gonna pull out the one
piece cocky anytime soon bro so what
what I couldn't get my head around was
okay are you blind and goaded or are you
blind oh yeah are you just surprised
and there are so many scenes that
flip-flop between the both because he's
still [__] done again he's kicking
ass and then there'll be points where
he's just like uh are you dead I uh I
can't tell I I can't tell and I'm like
how is this guy still alive I don't I
don't get it how how is this assassin
still alive it's like there's like
scenes as well where he's trying to find
the gun and he can't find him yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's good though like that's
like you know I don't need I don't want
to be dead so what you're saying is he's
a little bit too inconsistent yeah yeah
I just like I was I I like the I like to
disabled enough
I just wish he was more blind no no no
all I'm talking about is uh with
suspension of disbelief I I love batshit
crazy things right yeah but it needs to
make sense within the logic of its own
world if something doesn't make sense
with it within the logic of his own
world I just it just like there's it's
just like a pin pin prick in my brain
where I just like I can't ignore it and
just like I was going into every scene
being like so is he see a blind man or
is he like a Jedi it's not I was like
sometimes he's a blind man sometimes
he's a [__] Jedi Master [__] feels
the force does all that [__] and I'm
like is he blind or is he just yeah I
think it was pretty consistent I thought
it was all right and uh yeah there and
and I like the campiness the cheesiness
of John Wick this there are there are
some points that when that were just
like a little bit too far for me at at
some points in this where I was just
like okay this is uh which part such as
for example um well don't spoil too much
because I started seeing okay okay
I don't even know what to spoiler
I mean
let's be honest uh the the the main
the main the main villain of John Wick
was the most cartoonish kind of like
villain yeah he's great
he was he was like he was like way too
[__] cartoonish he was just like
let's just make that you you just like
that because he's just like a seeing a
Frenchman getting [__]
that's the British in you man
it makes sense this whole play this
whole world is kind of like cartoon was
he like a bond villain or something he
was like a bond villain sometimes like a
hundred he was like he wasn't that bad I
mean it's it's like he's like evil for
evil sake but it makes sense does he
have an evil mustache no he doesn't no
although I wouldn't be enough censored
in the world though in the the rules you
know yeah that has he broke the rules I
I think I think that I think that was
the thing that bothered me about John
Wick 4 because as you find out more
about the rules of this assassin world
because in like John Wick one and two it
was kind of like a surface kind of thing
where it's like oh this cool thing
exists uh these are what the rules of
the Assassin worlds are
um and you're like okay that's enough of
a background thing where I can just
focus on the action but what I found
with John Wick 4 was that it was so like
it was way more ingrained to the plot
line and then I had that like third
movie to kind of transition you into it
probably I mean no I I still I still
don't think I've missed much you did you
did I'm going to watch the third movie
and I'm gonna be like I'm gonna be like
okay so uh he hates this one that guy
betrayed that person thank you so much
in the third movie and he got another
dog
that's so much sick no but like what
what bothered me was there were just
like little inconsistencies I found
within the logic of its own world uh
where just some some like I'm I'm all
for suspension of disbelief but there
are just some things where it just took
things a bit too far when there was more
focus on it uh that just I couldn't
ignore it as much I don't know how
you're going so in depth into this like
probably more than any reviewer and kind
of retaliation is not
he's like the most plot heavy I'm gonna
watch the third man there's a lot of
plot that happens I'm a saying
everything that died this was explaining
to me was just like okay the person
betrayed that person that person is
friends with that person okay I
understand yeah the John Wick shoots the
fourth has like the least plot
like because he has like barely any
lines in it he barely says anything he's
like 200 words in the whole movie I mean
that was also consistent with like the
three other movies
no no the third is very plot heavy I
can't believe it I've only seen the
first one so I don't know I guess I've
seen now I've seen like three out of the
four John Wick movies and I guess I can
remember like two lies that he's ever
you're like Jojo Parts
but John Wicked it was not happy
it skipped part three that's like
skipping the second Lord of the Rings
film being like no okay
[__] but you're still missing important
plot points look I don't watch John Wick
for the plot I watch it before they
watch John wait for the plot the action
is a side bonus question shut the [__]
up
that's so cute I don't watch it for the
like amazing Oscar oscar-nominated
writing of John Wick Whose Line includes
yeah and I love it yeah
when he says yeah I get chubbed I mean I
mean likewise but it's not a plot Point
yeah it's like it's kind of uh yeah yeah
okay actually actually uh okay the one
the one scene that bothered me the ones
okay one scene that bothered me the
[__] uh there's a scene with a
literal [__] James Bond villain where
they play poker together and this is
really it's it's this really badass
scene where they play poker together and
the stakes are meant to be high the
poker game means [__] nothing because
they're like okay so the winner of the
the like the loser of the poker game has
to do X or has to do I can't actually
remember the stakes yeah of the poker
game but I remember being high stakes
and then and then they go through this
like 20 minute long scene it's not a 20
minute [__] off it's like five minutes
gone like they go through this long
scene reversal poker scene and then they
just start shooting each other anywhere
so I'm like okay
so the poker just the Pokemon nothing
it's the House of Cards Gone John Wick
like you could have just shot the bad
guy immediately and just foregone this
song they have to create like suspense
right they have to be like oh okay is he
actually gonna like play by the rules
this time or is he gonna be John Wick
and just start guns are blazing turns
out he's John Wick why am I defending
this movie
civilized political discussions in John
Wick like you know that was gonna happen
no no I'm like why are you I feel like
you're comparing this scene to like
she's like oh you can't just have him
run up in a place you'd be like all
right people I I I mean I the thing that
bothered me was just like why are we
pretending why are we pretending to have
a plot here why are we pretending that
this means anything
like I said John Wick that's exciting
like did they really need poker and
Casino Royale like did they come on they
didn't matter in the end like you need
that that's like what the [__]
I'm like we should remove all dialogue
from films I feel as I feel maybe they
added that scene because after four
movies and you know many many different
scenes and situations John Wick shooting
[__] they're probably just like all
right we gotta change it up uh we've
done a building we've done a house we've
done the streets we've done the club
we've done every other place where have
we not shot guns at yet poker game and
they just throw that in I I guarantee
that's how it was chosen I love that
fight scene though the fight scene was
[__] insane all the fight scenes all
the fight scenes were so good oh my God
I'm just yeah the thing that bothered me
wasn't the fight scenes it was just like
I said
um you know I could turn my brain off
for the first and second one the fourth
one because there were so many more
moving Parts in the first and second one
it was just I just noticed too many like
internal inconsistencies with its own
logic in its world and that just kind of
like took me out I disagree I feel I
feel John Wick is just like the
live-action God of high school no no
it's just like the fight scenes are epic
but what the [__] is this plot disagree
is this area
John Wick has a better plot yeah way
better go to high school literally
doesn't have a plot sounds like John
Wick no job I can't believe you just get
this probably if you you have proposed
the idea of John Wick 4 and you're like
I'm Josh John week three actually no I I
didn't purposely skip John week three uh
didus just like refused to let me not
watch it he was like we're [__] job
we're [__] watching John Wick fall
together and you're sitting down I'm
like I haven't seen the third one and
he's like I don't care you are you
realize he just wanted to watch it and
he wanted to do that yeah so blame
dieters yeah I'll take it I'll take it
but you're not like watching John
Wickford you know what it made me mess
as you know I realized it's kind of like
three yeah
funnily enough not John Wick three
uh I don't know has it is it just me or
has there just been a decline of you
know old school martial arts kind of
like films right because it's hard
what'd you mean this like it's hard to
train for that like Keanu Reeves was
trained for [__] like decades and
doing that stuff yeah and I think that
it's just it just doesn't look nearly as
good as John work well yeah of course
yeah of course I'm not just like talking
about John Wick because Keanu Reeves did
train the [__] out of that
um he made a [__] Banger film I know
I'm like this is me nitpicking John Wick
forward none of none of these criticisms
actually matter you don't have caveats
but
um
yeah it made me realize that the last
like the last real martial arts movie I
watched was probably the raid the ray
two right and that was how many [__]
years ago now I remember back in the day
yeah I remember back yeah that was
it felt it felt like such a long time
ago you haven't seen it but you know
back in the day there are so many
different martial arts flicks coming out
but there hasn't been just a rising star
of just a martial arts film you know
main character like you know we had
Bruce Lee Jackie Chan Donnie Yen you
know I mean I feel those are very hard
names to live up to right yeah yeah but
that's the thing they're Legends yeah
um Jet Li as well there's the the there
used to be just so many right and so
many different martial arts films being
made and there just doesn't seem to be
any coming out right now it's it's like
swings around abouts right it's like you
know you get you get uh every now and
then you'll get like a fantasy period
where everyone's fantasy and they'll be
superheroes and then I'll be space and
then I think it'll come back around I
think it's just not it's just not I
don't think yeah I don't think people
are really that interested in martial
arts right now unfortunately and in a
broader scope so you think a lot of
people like who are really into that
kind of stuff are like I would rather
watch UFC or something actually it's
funny you mentioned that because I was
talking to this website he was like yeah
UFC has just killed martial arts films
I'm like I don't know if that's true
because a little bit I think because
there's always that there's always a
discussion like who would win the fight
Bruce Lee or Donnie Yen you know what I
mean and then Joe Rogan comes along and
he's just like well uh
done more bmts so highly likely that the
frogs are gay scientifically uh you
bring a MMA fighter in down there he he
wipes the floor with both of them it's
been proven every time you you you bring
an MMA fighter to a Kung Fu Master and
the MMA fighter wins every time I do
think there's a little bit of Truth in
that way like I think a lot of the I
don't know maybe I don't know like I
think it's more I don't know I I also
don't I felt that yeah there are not
many good movies coming out martial arts
movies and I also just don't really care
about it much right now kind of like
yeah whatever no I mean I watching John
Wick I was like that's basically a
martial arts movie hidden underground
that is a martial arts movie where guns
are the martial arts yeah right what do
you call like gun Jutsu or something uh
gun cutter they called it something they
had like an on-term yes it was gun
cutter which
no I can't remember uh but it came from
I believe equilibrium the film with
Christian Bale oh yeah uh that's where
the term kind of originated from and you
know a great movie where they kind of
made cool looking things I I've looked
way too deeply into this because I'm
like I [__] love martial arts films
so I'm like where did this come from and
you know there there was this fake
martial arts uh in equilibrium where it
was like it was meant to make it so that
you are you the way you move and the way
you are angled is makes you less likely
to be hit by bullets while also
optimizing how you can fire a gun would
you think about it for a second and I'm
like that's [__] [__] but also
you see some of the scenes in
equilibrium I mean like I don't care
that that's [__] that's awesome Epic
yeah that's [__] epic yeah but when I
watch UFC I'm like when I've seen it I'm
like I actually just don't want to see
two dudes nearly kill each other I think
I'm okay yeah I said enough on Twitter
so I think that part of my like medieval
bloodline kind of just let a few gender
I'm sure there was a time when we had
nothing better to do as a civilization
where that I kind of got something out
of that but like boxing I I've seen and
I kind of weirdly my brain I'm like this
feels a little bit better even though
she's people giving each other brain
damage yeah watching UFC I'm like this
is a little too much for me I'm like
these people look like they're actually
like being killed sometimes I'm like ah
I mean they they definitely run into the
trouble of that yeah I'm like the risk
um I'm okay like this is just like not
not it for me yeah yeah I'll go back to
watch it I'm just gonna play Street
Fighter yeah
maybe maybe I'm a beta male I don't know
I'm just like I just don't get joy out
of seeing dude beat the [__] out of each
other yeah yeah I've been on Twitter
enough yeah honestly yeah you see it on
Twitter every day I mean I you know I do
find some uh you know some sometimes I
see a UFC clip and I'm like damn that's
[__] bad absolutely like athletes and
they're amazing what they do but for me
it's just like I don't I'm good yeah the
compilation of like you know like
thousand IQ by UFC players it's like
like you know that stuff is like all
right yeah that's kind of sick yeah you
know when they'd like flip accidentally
or you know like any cool thing like
that but just a regular match I'm just
like like one I'm not really invested
and two I don't want to see people
getting hurt I saw this clip the other
day and it I don't know why it came up
on my thing but it was a UFC fighter who
was having like an asthma attack and he
was like get my inhaler get my inhaler
and this is like mid fight and then the
guy asked him like is it okay he's like
yeah it's FDA approved and he takes it
and then afterwards I guess the guy I
think his name is Dana White or
something he's like he's like yeah so I
actually uh he wasn't allowed to take
that that's actually an illegal
substance you absolutely cannot take
anything in the octopus and I was like
yeah because technically counts as
steroids right I I don't know what it is
I'm like do say what an asthma attack
man what do you want to die like what do
you like I I don't think he was he was
trying to get an edge I think he was
just trying to breathe bro I don't think
there was any any like like adrenaline
in there yeah if I was just trying to
live yeah to me I'm like doing really
need a sport where if a dude's having an
asthma attack we have to be like
absolutely not he needs to suffer it's
like ah I'm good I'm good I'm having
kidney failure Health it's like sorry
you're in the Octagon kind of don't do
anything about that yeah yeah yeah you
want to throw the match if you want to
get traded yeah I mean like boxing
fights right like if you're getting
beaten the [__] up they just call it
right they're like yeah stop the fight
yeah yeah yeah and you see it's like oh
you don't get to stop the fights you're
dead I've already been knocked out
because of how violent the sport is yeah
like it's like I'm like I'm good like
and I get it if you're into it I'm
totally fine with that I think there's
literally just a me personally thing I
yeah it's too much for me yeah yeah like
you sometimes you see Knockouts and you
hear that you hear you
I thought that to me is just like God
damn oh God damn
I heard that from here man his ancestors
[__] felt that God damn man I know
who are into UFC I feel like they're a
little too much into UFC you know what I
mean I don't know I have never met a UFC
fan I've had some friends who are into
it and they're like a little too into it
I'm like what are you why are you so
invested in this yeah I I know I know
quite a few people into UFC as well
really
um someone's a little too invested in
seeing someone like beating the [__] out
like two dudes beating each other up I'm
like I'm like it's a little I know I
think there is no because I I think
there is there there is that caveman
part oh for sure for sure yeah but from
what I found the people that are really
into UFC as well there's there's that
but there's also like you know there's
there's two different ways to view a
game right there's the haha who won haha
it's football go like ball go in the
gold goal post haha we cheer and then
you get to like the deeper level where
you start appreciating it as like an art
form just like oh there are the minute
there's the metagame there's the tactics
they're involved in this and for the
people I've known that are into UFC they
most of them are also doing martial arts
as well yeah they're doing some form of
Martial that makes sense you know so
there is an appreciation on just the art
form as well and then you get to see
someone knocked out you're like yo let's
go oh God damn my balls are expanding
from the amount of testosterone yeah
I don't appreciate it oh you're a lead
player
that's true and a balloon's tower
please Hollywood whatever Hollywood or
Asian Cinema give me more action films
give me more martial arts films I missed
you could always just go back to like
the back catalog right because like in
the in the 80s and 90s I feel those so
like
just go back watch all the old [__] and
then you can complain yeah
yeah there's only so many times I can
watch Kung Fu Hustle and be like oh this
is goaded and I'm like I watched that
when I was like 20 or some [__] like
that or no way younger Johnny is
actually still producing some
um in China I think he's still like
producing he just did a pretty big epic
but I think he used a lot of I'm not a
big fan of China bro I'm not a big fan
of the martial arts with the wires I'm a
huge fan oh yeah I'm not too I prefer
more grounded martial arts he's trying
to yeah because I watched like a like a
GQ or whatever it is one of those
interviews and he's trying to make like
a mix of superheroes mixed with martial
arts and I'm like yeah I'm good the
martial arts yeah because yeah like in
terms of like the martial arts genre
that was a genre I'd never got into as
well like the whole uh doing seven
backflips in the air yeah like Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon hero all that stuff
even though there are some beautiful
things huh Hero's pretty good I mean it
was beautiful but I will never take hero
over something like Ip Man or something
yeah but Donnie and vs Bruce Lee
Bruce Lee in hero
isn't it Jackie the chair no no no we
think of the same film I'm pretty sure
Bruce Lee is dead
sorry sorry am I to hologram of Bruce
Lee
I meant gently oh yeah sorry gently yeah
he's done again versus jelly I was like
oh my God yeah sorry what are you
talking about did you get your two Asian
martial arts actors
yeah jet leave versus Johnny Adam it's
pretty good I'm here that's like an
amazing fight yeah that isn't amazing
probably probably the best fight of that
uh it's like right in the start it's
like the first dude with the with this
part the spear and it's really yeah
cinematography in that scene insane they
did that they did like 80 takes as well
it's a crazy amount of takes they do
yeah it's insane yeah they were
dedicated I mean it's getting rarer for
you know to have these big martial arts
kind of like Superstars you need that
martial arts training hearing like what
some of these dudes had to go through
when they were starting like it was all
like Off Script there was no script they
would just do [__] and they would just
make [__] up and they would get thrown
off buildings thrown into glass like set
on fire it's like all right all right
now we're gonna throw you in a acid
didn't take it oh okay all right now
that you've broken your spine in three
different positions we know exactly what
we're doing it's crazy you see some of
the stones like Jackie Chan did and
you're like holy like that one of him
falling either police story where you
he's so there's a signal electrocuted
yeah all through the lights into all the
lights oh my God it falls out of that
like kind of like Spanish like old style
looking Town through like the tops oh
yeah eight of them that's [__]
terrifying he he I mean the level of
unhinged uh is just crazy yeah it's so
crazy in this like very few let's say
you know actors that still come in with
that mentality Steven Seagal let's go
okay it comes in with the mentality
let's get it done let's make a film
actually you know I kind of miss campy
80 action films I don't miss Steven
Seagal you know what I know he he like
went in his movies when he does them now
he makes them like sign agreements
saying that he doesn't have to stand up
what he films all his scenes sitting
down
[Music]
he's lazy as [__] he's and there's like
have you seen the interviews where he's
like yeah when Bruce Lee was dying they
called me first not the ambulance to ask
what to do
he's such a [__] psychopath uh
Stephen Segal uh sitting down in movies
let's see what comes up I feel it was
like a there was like a thing where in
every single thing he
yeah Steven Seagal movie out for a kill
is so lazy he sits fighting
how much do you think Steven Seagal sits
in his movies
wait so all of his fight scenes are
sitting down no I think in a movie there
was one where he was just sitting down
during a fight scene I think I think he
sits down in most of his movies right
that's how [__] lazy this guy he's
also just an [__] I've known great
things about him yeah
do you know a movie I've rewatched
recently that is not John Wick 3. uh not
John Wick three uh so I I forgot how
[__] goaded this movie was which I
don't think is actually goaded uh but it
was as enjoyable as I remember it being
uh so there's a street fighter live
action film oh my God
it's so good oh holy [__]
okay because uh Street Fighter 6
released recently yeah so I got randomly
recommended you know I've went down that
rabbit hole randomly got recommended a
clip of the live-action Street Fighter
with Jean-Claude Van Damme oh holy I was
like this was really good when I was
like 10. I I bet it's not as good
re-watching it as at like 33. I
rewatched it and God damn it is so [__]
it is so campy it is so cheesy but oh my
God it's such a banger that is
definitely your Nostalgia goggles toys
let me read sounds ass I don't even need
to watch it I mean it is awesome it is
us but it's the perfect amount of ass
that it flips around and just becomes so
[__] entertaining when you when you
when when you stop taking it seriously
it is one of the most I mean I never
took it seriously have you seen it yeah
of course it sucks dude
this is this is okay let me like the
reason it's so good right
is because this is what happens when you
have the shittest script known to have
you have the shitty script known to man
but for some reason every actor gives
110 yeah everyone every item they were
not paid enough
every actor like fully encapsulates and
fully sells the script even though it's
the shitty script the shittest lines of
all time for some reason every actor
showed up and was just like boys
I am giving you my a game and I'm just
like normally normally you see you see
films like this and you're like okay
obviously the actors are calling it in
no actor in Street Fighter called it in
and I'm like this is everybody else did
everyone else did and it's just such uh
it's just so much fun I don't know I
don't know why that film works I really
liked it I'm going to defend that I I
will defend the live action I wanna I
wanna hear I want to hear someone's
opinion of them watching it for the
first time with like no Nostalgia
goggles right right I think that will
truly see if it actually stands up to
the test of time like you've never seen
any
no okay I need I need you to watch it so
we can get like a fresh opinion sure
yeah unbiased opinion it is because I
feel you and I only enjoy it because you
know it's nostalgic for us for uh for
reference it is rated I believe 4.4 and
IMDb
it's a [__] film but it is entertaining
huh what's the plot
um what like what's the point of the
movie what are they doing M bison is
basically a terrorist trying to take
over the world so that uh
girl's the main character okay yeah and
he's played by John uh Jean-Claude oh
yes my favorite America
when they get a real American like
Arnold yeah
um yeah played by Jean-Claude Van Damme
and uh all of your favorite characters
are in it yeah
certainly in it
is like a spy or something uh yeah yeah
and uh they try to take down and bison
together and then spoiler alert they do
they saw a tweet that was like every
single country in Street Fighter got
like some form of weird skewed
representation of like a stereotype you
know like girls like this American Ninja
I don't know who the Russian dude is
like the big
thingy yeah and then they're like you
know chunley is like this you know like
a fighter and whatever and then they're
like yeah for Brazil it's [__]
Gremlin that is just [__] electricity
and it's like how is that representative
in Brazil like what are you trying to
say about Brazilian people they're all
like [__] Street goblins
yeah yeah like Blanca right like he's a
little [__] up but I completely forgot
he's from Brazil he's from Brazil what
the [__] they predated the Brazil memes
you even like that
every other country got like kind of
like a really weird jarring stereotype
and then they were like Brazil [__]
Gremlin [__] Blanco Goblin ass mouth
not even a [__] human being
what the heck damn they did them dirty
yeah like this kind of [__] up
this episode is sponsored by Mint mobile
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big Wireless
providers if we've learned anything
except there's always a catch so when we
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium Wireless starting at just 15
bucks a month oh we thought what's the
catch but after talking to them and
using the service it all makes sense
there isn't one mid mobile secret source
is that the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
the cost of retail stores and pass those
sweet savings directly onto you I
recently just actually used mid mobile
uh when I traveled to America and I
needed to buy an American Sim and I just
couldn't find a place to buy it but what
came to my rescue mint mobile genuinely
had no problems in America when I was
using it for anyone who hates their
phone bill Min mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month me
mobile gives you the best rate whether
you're buying for one or a family and
admit families start at two lines all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network so to get
your new wireless clan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com trash
that's mintmobile.com trash cart your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com trash back to the episode
I don't know if it's a Nostalgia thing
now I just kind of miss the kind of old
school action scenes and uh I think I
think John wicker Works something in me
well I was like this is gonna work
something to me
I want more I need more
bro if you're not chubbed up in that
movie you aren't watching the same movie
oh my God
just admit you want to [__]
look I was I was I was chubbed up dude
that fight that fight on the stairs
down the stairs I was like oh the the
the gamer scene you know you know what
I'm talking about oh dude that was
showing the gamer scene oh my God
just watch this watch before yeah I'll
skip two and three it's just like they
when they made that movie they were like
they must have known that no other movie
is gonna be able to compete they were
just like I mean no one has all movies
are canceled after John would fall until
John Wick five I think like this is it
gonna be a fifth one uh well they
actually well they teased they were I
don't know well
no I don't think so about that oh
perfect there will be a fifth one yeah
probably you're implying there was a
plot there originally for sometimes I
saw they announced that they were doing
it I was like what I don't know if
that's Twitter [__] but I was like
this is gonna be a five hour move but
either way we're getting a bunch of
prequels and stuff and yeah that
wouldn't surprise me I I wouldn't want
the John Wick franchise to die I'd love
to know more about the universe which
you said didn't exist
you know I I thought I you know I
thought I didn't and I did and I was
just like this assassin universe is cool
it is a cool it is a really cool like
idea like conceptually I [__] love
the idea of this assassin Universe where
the rules of their unit they operate
within their own rules of their universe
but like it's kind of like for me it's
kind of like the you know kind of like
similar to horror the more you find out
about something the less the less scary
it becomes the more I find out about the
Assassin Universe the less the uh the
less most interesting and mysterious
that it is and the more that I'm I'm
like finding poking like holes in it
like why is this a thing you know why
why do things work like this this makes
no sense okay uh so yeah that was that
was a big thing but I would love to see
more John Wick I would love to see more
action movies
it's called John Wick 3.
you have to watch that one yeah I'll
tell you what else I've been doing as
well okay
um I don't know why I've had so much
free time recently it's it's it's it's
it's weird it's mysterious
um I've been uh reading manga as well oh
what is that I've been doing I've been
doing doing a joke yeah yeah what have
you been reading uh I've been reading a
manga called the climber and it's I
think
a [__] Masterpiece actually here we
go
like like a like not like an actual mask
and I don't know how I would actually do
this it is not a new one uh it is a
pretty old one uh Coco noito
oh yes I have read the first couple I
think of that yeah George read
everything Joe's read everything in
existence Joey has read it there's radio
bust if yes I've read the first couple
volumes okay so it's like let me let me
show you it's the best sports manga but
it's not really a sports Market it's a
it's the best sports manga I've seen
since uh I guess Sports media is the
incense ping pong the animation
it is not a it's it's an anime about
someone who discovers like rock climbing
and free solo ink okay uh but it's not
it's not about that at all
um it like it's it's got a really
interesting story behind the story as
well because the first three volumes of
this manga is your typical like Shonen
Sports Shonen [__] kind of thing he
like enters this tournament he's he's
like he he has like high school Rivals
and then so what happened is that about
three volumes in uh the writer so there
was a there was originally a writer and
an artist team up and the writer just
left the writer for some reason just
left leaving it to the artist to come up
with the story so around about three
volumes in it just completely shifts
from this stereotypical Shonen Sports
manga to this like life manga and if
that was the point I dropped it so
that's why I haven't this is why hearing
this part is the first time because when
I read it I remembered it as just oh
it's a rock climbing yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so it's got It's like one it's
there's a few manga that I've read that
has made me feel such like Deep Emotions
as the climber has and okay so when the
right or left it got better it got
better so when the dude stopped hiring
the guy did it himself he just started
making better wow maybe I'm goated yeah
yeah yeah because I'll do it myself yeah
because like you know it's like spoiler
um not not really a spoiler but he just
basically just like stops the high
school [__] puts in a Time Skip and
he's just like okay yeah okay okay oh my
God yeah yeah this sounds amazing that's
all you want to see yeah he gets he he
gets out of high school right and really
starts to
follow the Arts of rock climbing
properly and properly tries to like for
he not only like falls in love with rock
climbing but it really uses rock
climbing as a metaphor this sounds so
[__] pretentious but like that's
that's kind of why it's so good it uses
it as a metaphor for his own personal
troubles and [__] that you hate people
for and you hate Society for because one
of the most one one thing that I think
was genius that the artist uh one one
genius thing that the artists realized
about rock climbing
um and free soloing right is so the
basis of the final plot is that he wants
to climb K2 which is you know the second
highest second highest hardest mountain
to climb in the world uh so you know
there are plenty of climbers that have
died while mountain climbing rock
climbing Everest K2 whatever
um and so what he used so what he used
mountain climbing like a mountain
climbing team for is he realized that no
matter what you can't pretend to be
someone you aren't when you're in a life
or death situation on a mountain yeah
right so when people are in a life death
situation when your survival depends on
your team members and what they decide
to do whether they leave a man behind
whether they go out into a snowstorm to
try and find some shelter or some word
or something to help the team to survive
you see people who who what they really
are the raw people beneath all of the
[__] masks that they wear in society
and that leads to some of the most like
hardest hitting moments and [__]
amazing panels I've seen in a manga I
might then did not come into it
expecting that from a [__] rock
climbing manga it is honestly I think
this manga is a [__] Masterpiece and
I've not heard a single person talk
about it so I'm I am talking about it
now if if you want to see uh if you if
you want to read something that I think
is a really really [__] underrated
manga uh that has some of the best Arts
I've seen in a long time like I'm sold I
feel that's the problem with like a lot
of mangas they're like because there's
just so much out there so much
especially that hasn't been animated
that you know obviously there are anime
fans and there are manga fans but I feel
right now the anime fans are kind of in
the Forefront talking about all the
shows whereas the manga fans are there
but they're not as the spotlight isn't
put on them as hard yeah yeah so when so
there's more instances of people finding
these like
super unknown yet super amazing manga
series that no one talks about because I
feel the spotlight is not on there yeah
I just get stressed out knowing that so
many manga are ongoing because this
one's ended this one's it's ended
see when it's ended I'm like yeah okay
17 volumes I think okay 17 volumes yeah
that's a that's a hefty amount I'll say
half the amount I mean I I can't it's
here's the thing okay I kind of realized
this after reading reading the climber
which is uh obviously I know in my mind
that Manga and Anime are different I
thought my medium of preference was like
anime but reading reading this manga do
you ever read a manga and you're like
there is no [__] way this could ever
be a good anime
and it kind of made me realize it's
gonna sound like really pretentious like
art student talk but reading something
like the climber it made me feel like
when the difference between a manga and
an anime is a manga is basically like a
one-person team right and there's
something about the visual storytelling
you can feel when you turn around turn
on a panel and you see amazing artwork
you there's a there's something you feel
you almost feel like a connection to the
artist or to the writer well it's like
it's like looking at a painting at an
art museum right oh just like this was
knowing that this was made by one person
and like everything about this painting
derives from this one person's mind that
it came from yeah and when you you see
like a painting that like really
connects with you you you almost feel
like oh I understand what this person
was thinking I understand what kind of
person
whoever created this thing is right so
like it makes that connection extra
special yeah well and I totally get that
because like with anime it's a massive
team yeah there's lots of different
people involved including the Creator so
I feel it's
a little I'm not saying it's impossible
but it's a lot more difficult sometimes
no matter how good the anime is to have
like that type of personal connection
yeah right because this this doesn't
apply to every manga only like the
golden manga where I'm like holy [__]
I'm I'm reading something so I'm reading
something that's making me feel
emotions that few media have made me
been able to make me feel and I feel
like I am this is something that the
author is telling me personally not not
anyone else this is this is something
that he's trying to communicate with me
because like
um the other example I can think of
right is uh villain Saga so villain Saga
is goaded in both anime and manga for
another episode today yeah yeah
another episode
it's one of the few manga that I feel
have has gotten an adaptation that is oh
it's so good that is yeah that is goaded
and faithful and then I think back to my
experience with the villain Saga manga
and I think back to the experience with
the villain Saga anime and it's weird uh
because it's like a subtle difference
but in the villain Saga anime it almost
felt like it almost feels like hey
there's there's like uh there's there's
the fourth wall you know what I mean
there's the fourth one I'm watching a
piece of entertainment and I'm and I'm
appreciating the story but it felt like
when I was reading the manga I was like
holy [__] I'm actually feeling what you
you know because you can you can nourish
like trying to say it trying to tell me
and I can't put it I can't really put it
into words but it's like a different
kind of like appreciation between Manga
and Anime I think you just described why
so many people love manga yeah yeah I
think I get it now yeah yeah I dude
Finland song anime is going so hard yeah
my favorite part of Vinland Saga other
than that it is absolutely an amazing
piece of media and you should watch or
read it whichever they're both they're
both amazing and you'll get whatever is
my favorite my favorite my favoritest
thing coming out of this everyone being
like maybe violence isn't that good an
anime
videos
said no to violence and that's kind of
cool how do we feel about that voice
yeah it's kind of like how like I've
seen more people because in in The Saga
right there is a big tonal shift in the
second part where violence kind of like
in the first part violence plays a very
big factor it's kind of glorify it's
kind of cool it's very hype and the
second part there's like they kind of
shifted to be like just extremely
oversimplified like violence bad not
good yeah and I've seen like the ratio
of comments people actually complaining
about the second Arc to people
complaining about people going to
complain about the second Arc is is
insane like there's I I cannot find a
single comment of someone saying uh
actually I found one or two yeah like
people saying the shock is boring
nothing's happening but I find so much
more comments you're being like people
just can't appreciate this they're going
to call it boring I'm deep because I get
it it's like shut the [__] up no one
cares it's a good show everyone knows
this is good I am that person no because
okay here's the thing I think a lot of I
think a lot of people uh expected that
uh just because that was kind of the I
mean I expected that I suppose myself
yeah yeah I expected that too I think
people will give me turn off it's funny
because I've seen a lot less negative
comments in regards to the anime because
when the manga started a lot of people
just ended up dropping it because
they're like oh this is boring now yeah
I think knowing that even though it is
still like half a year until like kind
of a bit of violence happens yeah of
anime run time I think in the manga to
be excruciatingly long if yeah and the
manga hoping for yeah and in the manga
there was no like back reference right
like no one could go to an adaptation
because this was the original Source
material where's the anime all the manga
fans are like coming out of there like
bunkers being like I'm telling you it's
good just wait stop complaining [__]
good man yeah I like how we're talking
about this after martial arts and John
Wick and UFC maybe violence isn't the
answer guys guys oh I mean I say that as
well and I like I immediately finished
the villain Saga episode I'm like all
right time to watch House Paradise it's
just indiscriminate violence yeah that
is just like violence 24 7. and I'm like
this is great I [__] love him from
villain Saga immediately so I'm watching
next to the health paradise and I was
like this is literally what they told me
it's a problem and I'm I'm still doing
it well I think it's because it's just a
different part of your brain but here's
the difference right here's the
difference a story like villain Saga is
going to stick with me it's going to
stay with for years to come hell's
Paradise as it is now I'm gonna forget
about it like in like two years I'm
still really I [__] love hell's
Paradise I'm enjoying the [__] out of
that actually I I think Demon Slayer
more like snore Slayer because it's so
boring nothing's happening I'm like nine
episodes in I'm like can something
happen please yeah I like I like hell's
Paradise because I don't [__] around
yeah like it's happening and Demon
Slayer they just [__] around so much I'm
just like just get to the Pod where
everyone is gonna start creaming their
pants we can have a 10 hour conversation
about the nuances of villain Saga but
also the hell's Paradise is nailing that
part of my brain that's like cool
it is the best like just turn your brain
off yay violence yeah I didn't go
straight when you put it in a tier yeah
above and then you put like oshinoko and
ass I was like get okay I agree with
that though no
why don't you agree with that dude I've
been watching all of us shinoko and I'm
like oh my God it's I it's for me it's
like cringe watching it why why the
whole like Terrace Terrace House Arc I
was like what the [__] is this [__] I
was like this wait why was that a cringe
oh cause look at the dude's like
the moment where I had I had this you
know you stand up you're like what the
[__] I was like when he like does this
whole like kind of Terrace House like
and if you don't know the Terrace house
there's a whole situation reality
romance yeah it's very unfortunate
situation and it was you know a a
contestant was on it and they ended up
and like unfortunately committing
suicide from all the mean comments and
the show kind of did like a weird kind
of parody of it I didn't really like and
it was kind of like it was super fast it
was like boom you're on the show boom
you have hate comments now you want to
die and then she tries to die and then
the dude's like stalking her I guess and
it's just ready to catch her and I was
like what the [__] is this what if she
didn't do it is he just following her
this whole time what the hell is this
this dude's a freak that was the anime
moment yeah and I was like and then this
dude
magically I'm sorry dude if you gave me
15 more lives I would not become this
much smarter I'm gonna be realistic
about it this dude became like Giga
brain ten thousand IQ social media
no and if you give me four more
minutes
so there is a high school version of
Terrace house so they're cut it's like
which is also like I was like what the
[__] is this I was like why are these 16
year olds on a dating show and like I
was just like yeah my Show's like that
in Japanese I know they do I know but
like I I it was just it was so corny and
and so on the nose I thought it was
really well done I thought it was a
really well done yeah yeah there's
there's few like normally when I see
let's say anime and manga manga
I was gonna say I was gonna say media
and I went MIA anger manga and media uh
Taco like internets kind of like culture
I think it does the best job I've seen
yeah there's still some moments where
I'm like oh this is cringe I feel I feel
like you say that because you are yes
like the industry you know so you know
how things like really really are it's
just how like there's also like another
thing where it was like
is where I really started getting pissed
off I was like oh my all of this episode
is just feels so stupid and they were
like actually don't worry no need to
kill yourself we have editing it's like
what what
they were like everyone's gonna love you
now and she's like no I don't want to
kill myself and it's like what is this
what do you think mental illness is just
an editing problem like I mean for the
TV station yeah yeah yeah especially in
Japan yeah I mean I thought I I don't
think I don't think it's a mental health
thing like and it's like let's fix it do
a tick tock dance let's film it and
let's get it going okay I think it's I I
got something totally different because
what I thought was genius about that
kind of Arc was just to show how fickle
the [__] internet which it is yeah
and I appreciate that that was what they
were trying to show and I understood
that but I I guess it was portrayed in a
way and maybe it's because there's the
Breakneck speed they went through all
this stuff they went through it pretty
fast I was like whoa it was definitely
more fleshed out in the manga yeah
because I remember this this Arc in the
manga lasting a little bit longer did
feel pretty fast in the anime yeah
um so yeah I was like oh I remember
watching the episode and it's like and I
was like oh we get into this Arc already
we're getting yeah and I think that was
also a problem with it is that they were
introducing these ideas and they were
running through them so fast and they're
trying to get this character are
believable for this girl who you know
because she gets online hate in this one
part we're supposed to believe that
within like just the time frame that was
with flip-flopping sides so often and
it's like
what the [__] no I I totally understand
that but I feel like the idea is that he
tried to portray were like still there
um which is why I still read it and
we've interacted with um the Japanese
entertainment industry in various ways
and it is very different to how we
operate uh obviously the agency having
way more power is your thing and also
Japanese hate comments being like Oh
yeah yeah ten times worse oh for sure
for sure Japanese hate comments are
intense yeah uh I don't know just the
when I was watching it I guess it was it
was it was a mixture of the rushed how
it was rushed and I guess because again
I walk in we're gonna work in that field
yeah I work in that I don't [__] do
work I play video games uh you know it's
kind of I mean interesting it was like
damn all I had to do was do good editing
and make a good video and everyone loves
me again damn phone is that easy for
some people that is how it works think
about think about think about how maybe
some people get uncanceled sometimes all
it takes is like what all it takes is
like the perfect apology video I just
need the one well-crafted video yeah
yeah and I guess sometimes that does
happen like that it's definitely
happened online but there's so many more
cases of like that not being the case
it's never that straightforward and it's
like oh yeah this is a [__] apology
video but in the episode the YouTuber
character in in that show explains that
yeah and so she's like I wouldn't
recommend you do this video because it
could backfire and I'm like okay you
know they're touching upon the realities
of the internet doesn't forgive us
obviously it's like dramatized because
it's a because because
it's because it's a [__] anime
obviously it's drum size but I
appreciated that they were saying things
and I'm like yo that's kind of that's
kind of like that's legit that's kind of
legit that's that's how that's kind of
legit for how things work it's a bit
more dramatic than what we're using
we're super dramatic and I guess that
they were trying to keep that like show
The Dramatics of it but then also not
commit to it because he magically turns
up from stalking her I guess and saves
the day which is that was weird right
like he's just he's like following her
in the street yeah I look at this guy's
a freak like I do not like the main
character I actually just I actually
don't like them either I [__] hate
this guy so much he's [__] weird he's
like Walmart light yeah
like it's oh my God I I can't stand him
and I think that's part of the reason
why I can't stand the show is that like
I do not care for him and the only
reason I watch this goddamn show is
because the opening is a banger and it
convinces me that maybe the show will be
good for five minutes I like it because
of the idea that presents and the like
topics that he explores yeah I agree
with you main character can be is the
least enjoyable character yeah yeah yeah
why'd he be a goddamn [__] basically
an Easter card why couldn't it just why
couldn't they've been so unlikable
goddammit
why do we have to be reborn yeah I mean
I I'm still enjoying Hills Paradise but
it is very much turn your brain off oh
yeah kind of fun yeah and there's
there's no there's only so much there's
only so much I can enjoy turn your brain
off kind of things yeah I think it
unlocks that part of my brain that
really loves the kind of anime Trope of
people the thing that kind of
terraformers gave me too it's like you
get to this new world when no rules are
similar to the world where you came from
yeah but we have these dudes who are
pretty competent and we can kind of see
how they can survive and how they learn
because they learn with you and I really
like that like you I think you mentioned
as well one time it's like the Dark
Continent Arc of Honey Hunter it's like
exploring a brand new world with these
[__] weird monsters and everything's
uh no one gets anything I love that
feeling it's like that feeling of
Despair that the characters feel like oh
my God we have to go up against this
[__] like yeah what the [__] yeah and
there's like a scene where there's like
it's not really scary because it's light
spoiler like there's the this dude's
just walking and then he feels a prick
on his hand on this weird land he just
immediately chops off his house oh yeah
yeah and then I was like that's [__]
sick
it's so soft it's level but I was like
it's true he didn't know what it was he
was like I have this [__] just weird
I'll do it I'm coming it's just
something about watching a bunch of like
[__] unexplainable badasses doing
badass things
it's just like the rule of cool you know
what I mean well I'm like I don't need
to think too much about this
um I just worry about how much of a
shelf life it can have because it's like
nothing but uh it can it can be like
really boring after like one season or
something but I think right now apart
from Finland sorry it's pretty the show
I'm enjoying watching the most but I'm
only watching like three shows so yeah
there's a there's a lot of people so
boring I'm I'm I hate watching Demon
Slayer this season I've decided I'm not
even doing that yeah Demon Slayer tried
I think the problem with this season of
Demon Slayer is that what made deem
Slayer great was the action the really
cool animation the action and then this
one was like oh let's have a bunch of
flashbacks to focus on the characters I
it's like Demon Slayer like you're the
the [__] meme of that kid with the
vine uh the the uh yeah it's like Demon
Slayer trying not to insert a flashback
challenge
it's like you should take a shot every
time you should watch demonstrate take a
shot every time there's a flashback
I feel I feel like there was one
flashback recently where the flashback
actually lasted longer than the [__]
fight I got so pissed off
we didn't watch you for the characters
okay okay I want to spoil something in
the new season because this this thing
pissed me off so much okay and it was
like and I don't know why it pissed me
off it was during the flashback of the
the hashira of the guy that were with
this time yeah and basically I guess to
make him like kind of have a whole Arc
and learn something they just figured
out the best way to make a character
learn something was to just make him
make him have a twin where he's
basically just he's his twin suffers all
the consequences and then that's his Arc
is that he'd learned from his twin and I
was like they just made another him
isn't it to make him learn the lessons
isn't that a Simpsons Treehouse of
Horrors I think so yeah like Bob's evil
twins it sounds exactly the same was
like oh he learned all of his story arcs
she would know like I guess there was
consequences he lost his twin but it
kind of felt like they were just making
all the punishment happen to his twin so
that he would learn and it was like
that's a weird like did you just think
what the [__]
ah I I just thought it was and also the
demons they're fighting are so boring
yeah yeah okay if if there is another
[__] high level demon who does the
[__] Uno reverse colors like oh no my
head is chopped off oh oh wait wait a
minute he's not dead and I'm like
[__] fool me want shame on me
fool me twice this is like the fifth the
fact that the Demon Slayer characters
still get surprised when they cut their
head off and they don't die it's like
has become almost like a parody of
itself like in a weird way where it's
like it all the rules they said just
don't [__] matter so so I'm gonna say
this this was this was recorded when
we're at about episode nine or ten I've
already walked up till episode yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh guaranteed by the time this
episode everyone's gonna change their
mind it's gonna be like this is the best
anime of the Season he did a [__]
backflip because DJI we're gonna get
another episode 18. yeah yeah exactly
exactly where I'll be like never mind
this show is golden exactly I the thing
I've learned about Demon Slayer is that
I uh it is a 10 episode handicap yeah
it is the most boring show for 10
episodes until it becomes good yeah and
then for some reason like it's it's
literally like that Rock Lee meme of
just like taking off the training
weights if this is like the first phase
where he's fighting Gaara and then every
season I'm like dim slay [__] this is
boring and then like you get into the
like the last three episodes and the the
training weights are off and you're like
holy [__] this is golden oh my God that
was so hard and then we repeat the cycle
all over again yeah they know when to
give you the cocaine yeah it's like not
now not now when you just get more and
more frustrating you're like all right
take a line now yeah all right I'm
satisfied yeah yeah I mean I the thing
is I'm still watching it I still I still
probably enjoy it I guess yeah oh man I
mean this talk is definitely uh not
motivated me the thing is like like God
said I think the moment that yeah I'm
gonna wait I'm sorry then everyone will
be like I'm gonna wait till the season
is over and confirm that there is
another episode 18 moment and then it
was like in The Last Arc right that the
the [__] when they just went insane
with it it was like oh this kind of I
would watch [__] 10 more episodes I
think I think the last talk was the most
consistently the best right yeah it was
so good yeah because there were so many
hype moments I think that I think that
Arc was the uh the outlier because also
that hasher was [__] fun to watch
yeah it was just a delight yeah this
hashra [__] snooze Fest yeah and also
like actually like seeing it was it was
this was like Midway through the
previous upwards like just seeing Nesco
kick ass for the first time you're just
like oh my God it's not just like a cute
little anime girl you know you could you
can ask you you can actually do [__]
actually useful yeah you're actually
useful
um but I think this most reminds me of
something like move and train or yeah
well I was like this is boring holy [__]
this last fight is hype about I think I
think it's most similar to something
like that the only thing I remember from
doing train is that last fight yeah
right the first hour and a half
and skipped the first like the four
episodes of Logan train I've it's
literally like compa uh compart
comparting into my mind where I'm like I
don't remember this no what happened to
that field and what happened I I
honestly thought because in this season
as well again another spoiler
um the so far uh [__] zenitsu and um
yeah the ball kid I forgot his name yeah
you know yeah no scared
aren't in it and I'm like theoretically
zenitsu's not there it should be good
now and it's like oh no this show is
still always
it's because I'm sure I don't [__]
very much it's because everyone
everything instead of being annoying the
harsheras are just boring
that's the the hushers I mean the
[__] girl I can't even remember her
name she's just there to uh she's just
there for the fan service
yeah she's she's had like one scene and
I'm like oh you're there for the horny
teenagers yeah I I understand now I
understand why you're there but I have
one there's there's always one there's
always that one
um but no I mean like generally the
anime has been pretty [__] great this
season yeah I'll watch more I just I
haven't had the time yeah same that's a
lie is there anything else that's good
this season that I should we should be
looking out for what you what you want
what you what do you mean just tell me
anything what's good what's great
not watching Gundam he's not gonna watch
Gundam no matter how good Gundam gets
I'm never gonna he's not gonna watch
Gundam but Gundam has reached that phase
where it's become Gundam again uh where
it's where it's just like oh here's
every war crime imaginable being
committed in one season I'm like oh okay
oh there's covering Japanese history
oh yeah are you watching uh Marshall
what I've read the Manga magic and
muscle oh no I wanted to though is it
good I think you'd enjoy that I it looks
like a show that I'd love it it's
probably a punchline Vibes right yeah
it's one punch man it's basically just
uh one punch man or mob psycho in
Hogwarts oh [__] yeah yeah basically
this gym bro yeah yeah I've I've seen
the synopsis yeah I wanted to read the
Manga but I was like well I heard the
anime is coming out the monk is good
yeah I'm hyped yeah yeah actually I will
I will actually watch that one yeah yeah
that's that's one definitely for you
um what else would you like have you
ever get another maid in the best I
don't want to see what kind of [__] up
well I mean he has to keep he has to oh
yeah [__] okay okay this one's this
one's this one's on a maybe so far
because I don't know if you'd enjoy I'm
waiting for the season ending to see if
it's worth okay okay
uh Heavenly delusion okay which is at
the moment is one of the most promised
anime I'm watching out there yeah it's a
lot of promising anime uh but it really
depends on how it ends so I'll come back
to you in two weeks okay tell me in two
weeks yeah yeah we'll see I'll come back
to you this is sounding awfully like
wandering priority right now
yeah
hopefully it doesn't end the same way
hopefully it doesn't end if I've learned
anything from from anime it's that
having a bang of first episode is the
easy part it's it's sticking that stick
in the landing yeah no because with a
show like this so the kind of basic plot
synopsis of this is that it's the it's a
post-apocalyptic world something has app
something has happened to the Earth we
don't know what it's one of those shows
where it doesn't treat you like an idiot
right it will show you a little bit of
lore a little bit of at a time and uh
you have all these different elements
that you don't know how they're all
connected there are monsters that
somehow roamed the knights killing
people oh I saw your I'm a big fan of
the gig Channel
whenever he uploads our watch uh I think
yeah you you've showed the bit of this
and I thought it looked really cool yeah
um and like there's like some for some
reason there's like a disease like
ravaging Humanity there's like some
reason there's double gangers that exist
in the world uh and you're like what the
[__] is going on and slowly slowly but
surely it's starting to like make sense
the more episodes go along but it's not
there yet at the big okay this is what's
actually going on so that's what it
depends on but in terms of the
production values I would argue that
it's probably the highest production
value show airing right now for some
reason it's almost like movie level
quality no way yeah it's like chainsaw
man without the CG okay how many
episodes left till it's finished
um so it is about three episodes left
till it's finished okay
um and yeah yeah yeah yeah I
he like keep keep it on keep an eye on
that keep an eye on it it's uh cool cool
cool it's very very good uh everything
else I don't think you'd be interested
in all right
I I know Connor's taste and I'm like you
wouldn't you wouldn't like any of this
stuff
[Music]
was great well thank you so much for
some more anime recommendations gone
I'll keep you updated on the Demon
Slayer hate see how that's gone no
worries no worries I kind of had the
urge to watch catch up on my hero just
to be like because a lot of people gave
me [__] for for being a hater and not
being up to date and I was like I might
do it just to be you know that's what I
did just like just so I wasn't worth huh
was it worth uh it was not worth I think
I don't know okay season six of my we've
[__] on my hero a lot but season six has
genuinely been
the best season in a very long time uh
they there is no High School [__] in
season six okay uh Deku goes through his
edgy phase and gets more interesting
cool I've seen pictures of that yeah
yeah just like that looks like
something's happening yeah I really like
him in fortnite yeah yeah it's like it's
like if uh it's it's like they were it's
like the author of my heroes just like
do you know what we need we need like
Tokyo Ghoul Vibes and I'm like this is
so cheesy but for some reason I'm kind
of interested again it worked into
Google yeah well thanks for watching
this episode hey look at these patrons
though uh they're probably watching
anime this season
yeah actually no this is patrons though
hey let us know what anime you're
watching currently and what you would
recommend down in the comments below if
you like to support the show then head
on over to our patreon patreon.com trash
taste also follow us on Twitter send us
memes on the subredding if you hate our
face listen to us on Spotify this has
been a very interesting episode of what
we get up to when we don't have trash
days recordings uh without a whole lot
of [__] nothing yeah
mine sweeper yeah we'll stop bullying
you we'll see you guys next week bye
foreign
[Music]